Peggy 18
hi my name is Colin Graham and I'm the
animation director of wash dogs today
we're going to take a look at some of
the ground breaking multiplayer gameplay
in the world of watchdogs everything is
connected
we took the online features and we
blended them seamlessly with the
single-player features of the game so
the single-player and the multiplayer it
all happens in the same world right now
we're going to show you how we can
connect to other players in three very
distinct ways online hacking contracts
CTOs mobile companion app and the
competitive decryption combat and
watchdogs everyone casts a digital
shadow all that information is out there
for us to see right now in the game
we're exploring the living City I'm
using the profiler to hack citizens I'm
looking for personal data I'm also
looking for bank accounts collecting
passwords and learning their secrets in
watchdogs these secrets will lead to
gameplay I was listening to these guys
on the bench and you can see that one of
them has an open online contract now if
I accept this contract I would actually
enter another player's game but I'm not
ready to hack another player just yet so
I'm going to keep going
I just got hacked there must have been a
contract out on me too if you look at
the mini-map at the bottom right it
shows you that somewhere in that circle
is another hacker I'll have to profile
everybody to figure out who the hacker
is just to explain to you what happened
let's rewind a bit and take a look at
this when I'm never cross over hi my
name is Carsten my hill from the
Assassin's Creed brand team I've been
invited to try out some of watchdogs
online features it's me that's hacking
into Colin's game and I'm going to show
you how I did that I've chosen this
inconspicuous vehicle and I'm going to
park up here and survey the situation
there's Colin over there as you can see
he looks like a random NPC he does not
look like Aiden in my game only I look
like Aiden in my game and of course
Colin looks like Aiden in his game now
I'm going to hack into that camera up
there and get a better view of the
situation so there's Colin again I'm
going to get ready to hack into his game
now he should be aware of my presence in
his game at this moment so he's going to
start looking for me so I'm going to
stay put and hope he doesn't notice me
back on my side I just can't find the
hacker I'm going to need to take action
I'm causing the citizens to panic we
want to see who doesn't react like the
real city but unfortunately for me one
of them is also calling the cops so I
can see the chaos that Colleen is caused
I'm going to stay clips and hope he
doesn't see me and try and complete the
Hat from here
on my side I've got everybody fleeing
the scene but I still can't find the
hacker somewhere in this crowd
he's hiding in a taco truck seriously
crap I just blasted one of the civilians
- that's not gonna be good for my
reputation I'm gonna have to take this
car and I'm gonna have to run them off
the road
absolutely getting hammered by the cops
my initial idea is a smoke not really
really started back
looks like I've just about escaped from
Colleen here I'll just hack this bridge
and raise it behind me just to make
absolutely sure and indeed I've avoided
being killed by Colleen which will get
me some notoriety points for a partial
success which will mean that I can
unlock some new skills myself grown
quite attached to this little taco truck
even though karstic did get away I still
spotted the hacker and I got some
partial notoriety points I'm gonna use
that to upgrade my skills tree Carson
thanks for coming by oh my pleasure
tons of fun now let's move on to
something different here I just accepted
a challenge to play against somebody on
the free CTOs mobile app you see this
helicopter that's controlled by a mobile
player he controls the helicopter and he
tries to fix the spotlight on me and he
also controls the face in fact he can
says anything that can be hacked and
he's gonna use all of that against me
the mobile flare has challenged me to a
race course he could be sitting right
next to me or he could be halfway around
the world sitting on a bus as Aiden it's
my goal to get across the city and get
through all of the checkpoints on time
mobile players goal is to try and stop
me
remember I'm still driving in the same
world I learn these streets from playing
the single-player campaign so I'm
familiar with the alleyways and the hack
of the levels I can anticipate all of
the hacks the mobile player
with the tap on the screen they can
explode steam pipes raise barriers but
cause massive traffic accidents for the
mobile player the city is truly in the
palm of their head
I'm getting hammered here because the
mobile player is redeploying the cops
I've been dodging all of his hacks so he
needs the help of the police officers to
run me off the road he tried to take me
out with a steam pipe hack and I managed
to slip past he knows as you will see
you think will send me a little message
this time we moved as with all the
online gameplay this is also going to
contribute to my skill tree now we're
going to join a group of friends to
steal into preposition but that will be
easy because we're not the only team
looking for it and here come my guys
we're going to have to storm this
building to get the file and there's the
other team david's flanking left to slow
them down and we're heading right they
managed to pick up the file before us
but decrypting it takes time so we're
going to get close and we're going to
interrupt the different phases and we
can kill them and take that fun
the trick is to use the environment to
your advantage you can generate cover
and can also create distractions where
the enemy is busy with all the movement
on the right I'm coming into the shadows
they drop the file so I'm gonna go get
it
here's David coming in for behind and
the file is ours to decrypt we just jump
ahead a bit we know the other team is
coming back so we want to lure them into
a trap
alright now that we're here we want to
keep them out of brain so they can't
steal the file back to us it's time to
get out of here
just push were you watching your team
inch the faster construction goes so
we're going to get moving and keep this
away from the other team
the other team is starting to lose so
they have to get close to this to have
to go back you don't want that to happen
so once again would usually environment
equate like hacking that's deeper
my team has changed strategy we've all
got our own cars in case we need to keep
the enemy away from the guy that's
holding the file they're close enough
again to interrupt my drip trip I'll
save you my jam coms jam coms
temporarily shuts down their hacking all
we need to do now
files decrypted victory is ours enough
playing with friends now I feel like
continuing my single-player campaign I
can see the Jordi's close by I'm going
to go see what he's up to
we've just shown you three different
ways that watchdogs allows you to
seamlessly connect your experience with
other players in the world of watchdogs
everything is connected we look forward
to seeing you online May 27
you